hello there steve kaufman here
um
you'll see that i got a my shoulder kind
of got a bit of a
bandage on it
i've got an ice pack there
i think i overdid my workout
some while ago and uh
and i got a rotator cuff injury and i'm
supposed to go and play in an old
timer's hockey tournament
uh next week and it really hurts i'm
trying to
see if i can with ice and
all kinds of exercises i was given
fix it although it doesn't seem to be
getting any better it's just getting
worse
uh anyway
today i'm going to talk about uh first
of all the recent flare-up on my blog
the linguist
on language on the subject of wikipedia
and
i tried to someone on the link forum
suggested that it would be a good idea
for link to have an entry in wikipedia
so i had a look and of course live
mochas there and rosetta stone and
pimsleur and i said sure why not link
so i went to
live mocha and i registered and i tried
to follow their instructions and it's
all very there's lots of stuff i mean
people are at least i am i often don't
have the patience to read through
everything and and we know that many
people who come to link don't want to
read they just want to get going and do
it
so i thought i was doing it right and i
was i had live mocha and rosetta stones
wiki entries up there and i was looking
at them and
and uh
trying to copy them and
i hadn't put in all the fancy footnotes
and references and stuff like that and
kind of written what i wanted to write
and i went off to lunch and i came back
and it was gone zapped
so i expressed a certain amount of
displeasure at that treatment
and it is annoying to me that people can
just take your work and zap it
just delete it speed delete like what's
the harm
uh
and so this
generated the liveliest
exchange of comments i've ever had on my
blog ran up to about 56
and a lot of people try to explain to me
that this is how wikipedia works and i'm
just stupid i didn't read the
instructions and i have no right to
complain
which is valid
but my perspective is that
wikipedia provides a service
i was a user i am a user i appreciate
wikipedia and i was prepared to be a
contributor
and i was contributing content which was
in essence the same as content they have
on other language systems i maybe didn't
get it right
they could have communicated with me and
said no that's not quite how we like it
please do this instead of just deleting
it
at link
lots of people have trouble with link
everybody who asks us whether they're
paying members or free members we take
the trouble to explain things to them
and i think any organization whether
they're for-profit not-for-profit free
they're all in the same business they're
in the a the business of providing a
service and b they hope to grow and
prosper as an organism as an
organization i make no distinctions
between for-profit not-for-profit or
anything else it's all human endeavor
uh human beings
a like to be successful in whatever
they're doing in whatever their project
is and human beings like to be treated
politely at any rate the debate raged i
was told that i couldn't accept
criticism i couldn't accept when i'm
wrong all that kind of stuff just
because i didn't agree with what
everyone else was saying or not everyone
but a lot of people anyway enough of
that i think we've exhausted ourselves
on that one
um
i also posted
some thoughts that i had on how link
could be used in a classroom
and i hope to get some feedback i see
val in tokyo has come back and i want to
talk to her and she has some suggestions
that my approach may not work and so i
really want to learn about how
people who are familiar with link might
use link in the classroom i've put my
ideas up simply just to get the
discussion started so what i want to
focus on today is
it has to do with with flashcards and i
had a
comment from someone who follows my
videos here
and thanked me and said that it helped
you know inspire her to learn more
languages and so forth and that she's a
student and she's very keen on languages
and she's now
deciding that she has decided she wants
to go after russian and spanish and
she's trying to do russian and she finds
it very difficult and she reviews her
flash guards both at link and in anki
and whatever hundreds of times i still
can't remember them do i have any advice
yes my advice is my advice is don't
overdo flash cards
uh i think there is far too much
emphasis placed on flash cards whether
it be space repetition systems
uh what was it called super memo anki i
mean those are all fine
as an adjunct to a language learning
program in my view now other people may
have different approaches but to me
max five percent of the time that i
spend in language learning is spent
reviewing flash cards and there are a
few reasons first of all in my russian
studies
i can't remember the numbers exactly
link tells me that i have saved 25 000
links
and i have learned 55 000 words
and
as i've said many times learned means or
that
knowing a word means that i know what it
means it doesn't necessarily mean that i
can use it
any language learner has a far larger
passive vocabulary than active
vocabulary nothing wrong with that you
still know what the word means you can
read you can listen you can understand
now when i read something new at link
the new words to me are in blue and they
largely correspond to words
either that i don't know or that i just
haven't come across before in fact i
know many of them i know most of those
words so that number 55 000 to the to
the extent that it's reflected in what i
see when i open up new content at link
is quite accurate so in three years i've
learned 55 000 words
i have saved 25 000 words there is no
way that i would have enough time
nor would i be inclined
to spend enough time
reviewing flash cards in order to learn
those words
so when you review flash cards you're
seeing the words as flash guards it's
you're seeing
you're able to focus on a few of them
relationships between different words
it helps to some extent some of them
when you go through the flash cards
you'll get them right away some of them
you will never learn you can review them
100 times you won't remember them
it's far better to spend your time
reviewing these words in their natural
setting
reading and listening particularly in
link where any word that you have saved
is now highlighted in yellow and that
helps to trigger i find my memory so i
see the yellow word i see the meaning
when i hover
i see it in a new context i'm reminded
that this is a word that i've saved
before
that's how i learned plus you pick up a
lot of words especially the way we count
words in link we count every
form of the word as a different word so
chances are when you've learned one form
of the word pretty soon you'll be
picking up the others without having to
save them
so
between reviewing the words you've
already saved when you read
and
seeing related words
guessing at them plus other words that
you pick up through context because you
now know more and more words
the main activity should be reading and
listening
and i mean i know that i spend i would
guess five percent of my time
on reviewing my flashcards i do it when
i get my flashcards by email because
typically
the uh the way we work at link when i
get my email
with with my saved links the bulk of
them are ones that i've saved recently
so they are relatively fresh in my mind
the context where i saw them is
relatively fresh
so i have a better chance to get a bit
of a head start on trying to learn them
sometimes if i'm busy and i don't review
my daily uh email of flashcards then
they've already kind of become frozen
but that's okay too because the next
time i run into them in my reading
they'll become they'll thaw out for me
you know and words that you are never
ever going to encounter again in your
listening and reading that you came
across because you need it for one
lesson and you saved it and it's now on
your flash card list and you can never
remember it and it's the type of flower
that grows in northeastern siberia or
whatever the word is
forget it it doesn't matter you won't be
able to remember them all focus on the
ones that keep on coming back spend most
of your time listening and reading and
writing and speaking and so forth and
don't overdo flash guarding whether it
be with link anki super memo or whatever
to me it is a relatively inefficient way
of learning far better to get in there
with a meaningful context get some
emotional involvement create some
context remind yourself that you've seen
the word before and you'll find that
before you know it you're able to read a
lot and you know a lot of words
so there you have it that's the end of
my uh little discussion today thank you
for listening